what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explain and
today we're continuing our celebration
of black history month
and focusing on one of the singers out
there who will never be as good as
whitney houston
or mariah carey beyonce knowles
and she played time and a talent force
dancing at an early age all right it's
been real
it's nope nope stop
my fiance is an enormous beyonce fan and
she won't hear a word against her but
for really for true beyonce was born on
september 4th 1981 in houston texas and
she displayed an interest in and a
talent 4
singing and dancing at an early age but
by the time she was 8 beyonce along with
friends kelly rowland and latavia
robertson would form a group called
girl's time in 1993 girl's time would
appear on star search it was basically a
show where undiscovered acts could
showcase their talent on a national
scale now girls time didn't win
but just appearing on star search was a
huge deal because the show was
incredibly popular in the 90s and some
huge acts originally appeared on it like
britney spears the backstreet boys
justin timberlake and too many others to
possibly name
them all but in 1995 beyonce's father
matthew became the group's manager which
required him to quit his full-time job
and put their family in a tough spot
financially but girl's time was signed
with a talent agency in 1995 and began
recording an album the next year which
led to a deal with columbia records now
in 1996
girl's time was renamed to destiny's
child after a passage in the biblical
book of isaiah the group consisted of
knowles
roland roberson and latoya luckett and
in 1997
one of their songs would be featured on
the soundtrack of the film
men in black and they released their
first single no no no which went on to
number one on the billboard r b chart
and number three on the billboard hot
100 and so destiny's child released
their self-titled album in 1998 and
followed it up in 1999 with the
multi-platinum album the writings on the
wall which featured several hit singles
including the number one singles bills
bill's bills and say my name
say my name i remember but they really
seem to have an affinity for just giving
a song a title and just giving it the
same name three times seems a little
weird to me but even as the group
appeared destined for super stardom all
was not
well within the group itself as luckett
and roberson had become frustrated with
the management of matthew knowles
claiming he showed favoritism towards
his daughter and kelly rowland and so in
2000 both roberson and luckett left
destiny's child and were replaced by
michelle williams and pharah franklin
the latter of which would leave in a
matter of months
transforming the group into a trio and
so in 2001 destiny's child released
their third album
survivor which would also be insanely
successful and they would not stop
playing
that freaking song on the radio and it
earned the group a grammy for best group
r b performance but despite their
continued success later that year the
group decided to take a break so that
each of them could focus on their solo
careers the next year
beyonce landed her first role in a
feature film playing foxy cleopatra
and austin powers and gold member but in
knowles also starred in the fighting
temptations alongside cuba gooding jr
now it was around this time
that beyonce first collaborated with
hip-hop legend
jay-z appearing on his track 0-3 bonnie
and clyde and would later appear on the
lead single
for his first solo album crazy in love
which would become beyonce's first of
many number one singles but this
collaboration
led many fans to speculate that beyonce
and jay-z were romantically involved and
that speculation would be confirmed when
the two of them appeared together on the
red carpet of the 2004
mtv video music awards now the album
itself titled dangerously in love would
go on to sell 11 million copies and
would net beyonce
five grammy awards which set a record at
the time but rather than following up
with this success with a second solo
album beyonce reunited with her
groupmates to record a final album with
destiny's child supported by a worldwide
tour now today destiny's child has sold
60 million records produced 10 top 10
singles and received a star on the
hollywood walk of fame so even though
this
era of beyonce's career sometimes gets
overshadowed due to her success as a
solo artist destiny's child
was an enormously successful group but
on september 4th 2006
on beyonce's 25th birthday she released
her second solo album
b day which like her debut album went to
number one and also won the grammy for
best contemporary rnb
album now she continued her acting
career as well appearing in the pink
panther and dream girls for which
knowles was nominated for a golden globe
award for best actress in a motion
picture musical or comedy now in 2008
beyonce scored her third consecutive
number one album with the release of
i am sasha fierce which according to her
is her alter ego that she created while
making crazy in love and who she
describes as being too aggressive
too strong too sassy and too sexy but
despite mixed critical reviews the album
produced some of beyonce's most
successful songs
including the number one hit single
ladies along with halo
and if i were a boy now on april 4th of
that same year beyonce and jay-z were
married but did so in secret
and waited a while to reveal it to the
public the video for single ladies
proved to be extremely popular
and was nominated for best female video
of the mtv video music awards in 2009
which was ultimately won by taylor swift
prompting
kanye west's crazy self to infamously
interrupt swift's acceptance speech to
proclaim that beyonce should have won
while beyonce looked on from the
audience in shock now single ladies won
video of the year the top prize of the
show anyway which made the outburst
even more cringe-inducing but the 2000s
turned out to be a great decade for
beyonce not only did she net
more top 10 singles than any other women
during that decade but she also released
her sixth
number one single a collaboration with
lady gaga titled telephone which tied
both of them with mariah carey for most
number one singles since the inception
of the nielsen's top 40 airplay charts
in 1992. now she performed at the first
inaugural ball of president obama and
her third album was nominated for 10
grammy awards tying the all-time record
for a female artist nevertheless
she announced in 2010 that she'd be
taking a break from music
and also ended her professional
relationship with her father but beyonce
kicked off the 2000s by releasing her
fourth solo album simply titled four
on june 28 2011 which like her previous
three albums went to number one and on
august 28th she took to the stage
at the vma awards and announced that she
was pregnant her first child blue ivy
carter would be born on january 7 2012
although she revealed in a 2013
documentary about her life that she'd
previously suffered a miscarriage but in
early 2013
she'd be invited to sing the national
anthem at obama's second inauguration
and would also perform at the halftime
show of super bowl 47 and will return
three years later for super bowl 50. if
i'm being honest with you guys i think
her performance during super bowl 47 was
actually better than her performance
during super bowl 50 but really
at this point listing off the successes
of her career
kind of becomes repetitive practically
everything she's done
especially within the realm of music has
been an overwhelming success her
self-titled fifth album
it debuted at number one on the charts
despite there being no publicity for it
leading up to its surprise release
her sixth album lemonade it also debuted
at number one making her the first
artist in history to have their first
six albums debut at number one on the
billboard 200
in 2018 beyonce headlined the coachella
music festival in
indio california and her performance
which also saw destiny's child reunite
for the occasion
became the subject of the netflix
documentary homecoming it's also the
album
that i play for my fiance whenever she
doesn't want to get up in the morning
but it does get her going but on the
personal front there's been
a bit of controversy between beyonce and
her husband jay-z
with a notable example being the leaked
surveillant tapes showing beyonce's
sister solange hitting jay-z while the
three of them were in an elevator in
2014. now this incident led many to
speculate that solange was angry at her
brother-in-law over alleged infidelities
but the motivation behind the
altercation has never fully been
explained but later that year beyonce
and jay-z
embarked on an international concert
tour but rumors that their marriage was
in trouble persisted now these rumors
gained more traction after the drop of
beyonce's lemonade album which contained
songs with lyrics that seemed to imply
that jay-z had actually cheated with one
track specifically mentioning becky with
the good hair which many interpreted as
a reference to be jay-z's mistress
rumors of their marriage being on the
rocks began to die down when they began
appearing together more frequently and
in 2017
beyonce announced that she was pregnant
again and she gave birth to twins named
rumi and sir now it's really uncertain
how much of the drama surrounding
beyonce's marriage was factual and how
much was rumor but the couples remain
married for 12 years at this point so
themes seem to be going okay on that
front but i will say this
if you marry a man who makes rap songs
about money cash and hoes can you really
be surprised
that he cheats on you so yeah other than
those personal issues there really
hasn't been much controversy surrounding
beyonce she's just proven to be an
incredibly talented and successful
artist that has stood the test of time
she's amassed a hugely devoted fan base
that refer to themselves as the beehive
and refer to her as
queen bee she's also been featured on
the time 100 list of most influential
people on multiple occasions and has
even added phrases like put a ring on it
and i woke up like this
into common usage and even created a
word that got added to the oxford
english dictionary that word of course
is bootylicious but beyonce is an
unquestioned
icon of pop culture and she's not even
40 years old and it doesn't even look
like she's going anywhere
anytime soon so with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end
if you want to see more of our pop
culture icon or black excellence videos
make sure you check the end screens here
at the end of the video and we will
catch you all later
peace